[Music]
this morning in our saturday session ani
defranco
it's easiest to call defranco a folk
singer but this buffalo born singer
songwriter
has never been constrained by one genre
her new album
revolutionary love is heavily influenced
by jazz
critics are calling it searing and
hopeful we'll hear her perform songs
from that album in a moment along with
the defranco classic
but first we sat down with her at new
york's legendary
irving plaza
how bad you want to be back here just
being this close to this
scene of my many crimes just makes me
want to
dive back in recently renovated though
still closed by covid
irving plaza is one of the venues that
helped establish
any defranco as a singular talent
buildings and bridges are made to bend
in the wind
independent adored and prolific
[Music]
her latest revolutionary love is her
22nd album
what is revolutionary love for me it's
basically
about showing up to the hard labor
of good change of truth and justice
with love in your heart is it about
loving people you really don't want to
love
absolutely i live in two different
worlds
simultaneously one of the videos for
this new album got her cited for
trespassing on oil company
land an act of artistic activism that
put defranco before a judge
just before our interview you just got
arrested recently and we're in court
and we're in court this morning yes zun
court
zoom court is about as fun as zoom
anything
defranco's passions by this point have
taken her around the world many times
over
but it started in a house that could be
stifling
in buffalo new york you grew up in a
house with no walls
how does that work my mother was an
architect and my father an engineer and
this was their
baby this was their project this house
it was a carriage house that they
turned into our family abode
and their vision was to have no walls to
have only
intimacy and togetherness i guess
the only door was on the bathroom my
family it
didn't work so great it's not great
because my family was not at peace
at the age of nine defranco met a local
musician
who introduced her to the buffalo folk
scene at 15 she moved out of the house
and by the early 1990s wound up in new
york city where she became an indie star
our apartment was the fifth floor there
was i think
eight of us that live there do you ever
just want to give up
sixteen years ago she made the move to
new orleans finding motherhood
and a second marriage you've had
difficulties in your marriage
and you've been open about them marriage
is hard
can be and uh it was really difficult
uh for my fella for a lot of years when
the kids were little
and he was holding down the fort all by
himself
and you know you you are struggling
in these different spheres and you grow
apart
and resentment build but this
album this new album of mine is sort of
like
the breakup album without the breakup
we made it through
[Music]
defranco has produced and distributed
every single one of her albums
independently on righteous babe records
has there ever been a moment when you've
regretted not doing a major label
studio album i don't
think so in working with a big time
producer
well it's hard to know about the road
not taken right
you know actually
i changed my answer i've regretted it a
lot
and thought along the way that is a more
true answer
i look back at some of the things that
i've recorded
and i think dang those are some good
songs and i didn't do them justice and
if only i had brought in the team of
professionals
you know i was just a kid with a
stubborn stubborn kid who was just like
i'm not going to wait around for the
team of professionals i'm going to do it
it's not perfect but hey but sometimes i
do look back at my records and i think
sorry songs
[Music]
defranco's brutal honesty is something
her dedicated fans have seen for more
than three decades
and it sounds like there is much more to
come
[Music]
i hope that i have helped more than i've
harmed
it always felt ironic that i was
described again and again and again for
decades as an
angry woman you know because it's an
easy label
yeah but i feel like i've always come
from that place of revolutionary love i
love
my country and that's why i fight for it
in my way you know it's all out of
out of love